on va passer à un tout autre sujet
maintenant ils vont participer à un raid
humanitaire pendant un peu plus d'une
semaine Clément Morichon et Flavien
Castanet bonsoir vous êtes à distance
avec nous
bonsoir alors
vous êtes à Biarritz mais vous à
Biarritz mais vous venez tout de même
des Yvelines vous venez de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux donc là vous êtes
à Biarritz parce que demain ce sera le
départ du 4L Trophy alors première
question est-ce que vous êtes pressé de
ce départ comment est-ce que vous vous
sentez
un jour du départ
alors oui on est très pressé mais
aujourd'hui on a surtout été très
stressé parce que aujourd'hui il y a eu
des contrôles techniques et il y a eu
des petits problèmes au dernier moment
qui se sont qui viennent de se régler
donc maintenant oui on est pressé de
partir et
de l'aventure
c'est une première participation pour
vous
oui
d'où le fait d'être un peu stressé je
suppose
exactement on savait pas trop comment ça
allait se passer cette journée de
contrôle et ben on a beaucoup appris
mais il y avait des petites choses qui
n'allaient pas des petites surprises
heureusement le contrôle technique est
passé et alors nos deux journalistes
Patrick Jacques de Dixmude et Gabriel
Gonthier vous ont suivi pendant votre
préparation on regarde tout de suite le
reportage
[Musique]
à 22 ans Ligny Montain Clément Morichon
s'apprête à vivre une aventure hors du
commun avec son coéquipier Flavien
Castanet il s'élanceront pour l'édition
2023 du 4L Trophy mais avant le grand
départ l'heure est à la préparation pour
Clément je suis en train de préparer le
4L Trophy donc là c'est tout le matériel
que je vais emmener pour si jamais j'ai
un pépin mécanique chose que j'espère
arrivera jamais mais donc du coup voilà
je mets tous nos classes c'est tout ce
qui va être côté sécurité la course se
déroule dans le désert l'équipement de
sécurité et d'entretien du véhicule et
primordial du coup c'est extincteur donc
ça c'est les lampes de détresse si
jamais je suis perdu dans le dans le
désert après donc une batterie de
rechange si j'ai un accident le triangle
mon matériel c'est jamais j'ai besoin de
faire de la mécanique sur sur la 4L
après ici on va avoir tous les produits
d'entretien et pour faire les mécanique
liquide de refroidissement qui est super
important dans le désert
et puis après ici ça va être toutes les
parties mécaniques donc là ça va être
tout ce qui va être système de
refroidissement les pales de ventilateur
les durites une fois le contrôle de
l'inventaire fait petit tour du côté de
la voiture donc là du coup la voiture
elle date de 1984
c'est une fourgonnette F6
1100 cm3 c'est un moteur Cléon donc
radiateur à l'avant et donc du coup bah
là on a moi sur ce moteur là j'ai
surtout touché à tout ce qui est donc du
coup carburateur et à l'humeur mais pour
la faire démarrer l'étudiant a dû se
mettre à la mécanique je n'y connaissais
rien du tout au début c'est vraiment
j'ai tout appris sur Youtube c'est ça un
peu la force de notre génération
maintenant c'est que tu peux tout
regarder tout apprendre sur sur Youtube
et sur les forums tout ça l'équipage a
également du aménager le véhicule qui va
aussi être le lieu de vie pendant la
course du coup est-ce qu'il faut savoir
derrière c'est qu'on a fait donc du coup
un aménagement on a refait toute la
menuiserie à l'intérieur donc là en fait
là ça va être ça va nous permettre de
dormir dessus donc en avançant un petit
peu les sièges je peux baisser la plaque
j'ai un mètre 75 pour pour dormir en
dessous
exactement la chambre à coucher après il
manque juste un petit matelas pour pour
être tranquille et après en dessous donc
là ici j'aurai des baquets donc que je
suis en train de préparer là on aura
deux grands tiroirs pour mettre mes
pièces mécaniques ici
à côté on aura des petits paquets en
plastique pour nos vêtements et puis
tous les vivre qu'on aura besoin parmi
leurs équipements également de nombreux
sacs et fournitures seront distribués
dans les villages aux enfants
des sacs avec donc s'il y a pas de silo
faut que je mette des stylos et on
mettra des je vais mettre des cahiers
dedans agis - 1 avant le départ des 1200
voitures participantes l'objectif pour
le duo yvelinois est avant tout d'aller
au bout de l'aventure et de soutenir
l'association Les Enfants du désert
alors pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
décidé de vous lancer dans cette dans
cette aventure Clément mauricon et
Flavien Castanet
tout d'abord pour le Défi donc ça soit
l'autonomie que ça soit avant le raid
pour la préparation mécanique trouver
des sponsors gérer une association et
après oui
le côté humain est aussi aventure
au Maroc avec une voiture qu'on ne
connaît c'est pas trop avant on a
préparé nous-mêmes et après là-bas c'est
de l'entraide c'est aider les autres qui
galèrent nous aussi on a un problème on
espère que de viendront nous aider heure
de belles rencontres
oui parce que vous allez traverser donc
trois pays la France l'Espagne jusqu'au
Maroc vous allez vous arrêter à
Marrakech à bord d'une 4L une voiture
quand même assez ancienne on l'a vu dans
le reportage il faut avoir des
connaissances mécaniques c'était pas
trop dur d'acquérir toutes ces
connaissances mécaniques
non quand on a un projet en tête et puis
c'est du plaisir de d'apprendre
justement dans le domaine qui est la
mécanique
tout le monde
Régine vous aviez une question oui j'ai
une question est-ce que vous avez une
idée de combien d'heures vous allez
pouvoir par jour
on va être sur du 5-6 heures minimum par
jour après par exemple aujourd'hui pour
venir à Biarritz hier pardon pour venir
à Biarritz on a roulé 10 heures de route
on avait 800 km à faire après par jour
on aura on va dire entre 100 et 200 km à
faire par jour mais ce sera dans
d'autres conditions et peut-être pas sûr
de la salle et donc ça va votre 4L elle
a tenu la route pour de Paris enfin de
Montigny jusqu'à Biarritz
la mécanique a bien marché
[Musique]
trop perforant
tout un raid humanitaire puisque le but
c'est quand même d'aider l'association
Enfants du Désert vous allez distribuer
des fournitures scolaires dans des
villages marocains est-ce que vous savez
déjà dans quel village vous allez devoir
vous arrêter
non alors là c'est vraiment le but du 4L
c'est que une fois qu'on arrive à Tanger
on nous donne un petit robot qui à la
boussole et on connaît pas le
l'itinéraire qu'on va faire mais on sait
qu'on va passer dans plein de petits
villages c'est ça
on ne sait pas lesquels
et donc à bord de votre 4L vous avez
quoi des stylos des cahiers
des classeurs des sacs pas mal de sacs
de notre école
et
quelques trousses
et donc vous allez devoir vous orienter
uniquement avec un GPS enfin ça va vous
êtes bon en orientation si jamais il y a
des des coupures
on sait lire une boussole et puis
boussole encore une fois c'est
l'aventure
ça vous tenterait vous autour du plateau
de partir à l'aventure comme ça de faire
le 4L Trophy ah ouais totalement ouais
Régine
moi aussi surtout que c'est pour une
bonne cause donc finalement elle y est
aventure et solidarité pourquoi pas oui
au revoir l'orientation mais
pour la bonne cause évidemment et alors
je vous pose aussi la question Tony
chassas vous allez parler dans un
instant de votre nouveau court-métrage
jamais sans mon tel mais est-ce que du
coup ça tenterait cette aventure pour la
bonne cause toujours que des partants
autour de la table est-ce que on pourra
suivre vos aventures sur les réseaux
sociaux
oui on a un compte Instagram
les sièges 4L 2023 on mettra toute notre
aventure sur sur Instagram et après sur
nos réseaux sociaux
et ben on vous souhaite une bonne course
et puis on vous suivra tout du long de
cette aventure merci en tout cas à vous
Clément Morichon et Flavien Castanet
d'avoir accepté notre invitation bonne
course
merci beaucoup